instead of devoting his time and effort
to taking this pandemic seriously
President Trump is hosting campaign
rallies packing thousands of people
tightly together without masks in direct
opposition to the guidance of all public
health experts just so that he can hear
the crowds chant his name clearly this
president has decided the best strategy
to do with the greatest threat against
this country during his presidency is to
bury his head in the sand and wish it
went away dr. Redfield as a director of
the CDC your advice to the president is
important now more than ever
dr. Redfield when was the last time you
spoke to the president about the
country's response to this pandemic
Thank You congresswoman as I mentioned
before the interactions and discussions
I have with the president I'll keep to
myself but I do meet with the task force
to read fill I'm not asking for your the
content of your conversation I'm asking
when you talked to him last it's been a
week a day a month again I'm gonna stay
with my same man to answer that I
continue to talk with the task force
whenever the task force meets Atlanta
and I think Thank You dr. Redd Phil I
think the fact that you won't tell this
committee when the last time you spoke
to him where there was days or months
ago is a real concern dr. Fauci when is
the last time you spoke to the president
about two Nayef weeks ago
thank you dr. Fauci Admiral when is the
last time you spoke to the president it
was a it was about two and a half weeks
ago as well maybe three weeks ago um if
you don't mind me just me clarifying
because I do think it's really important
I'm I'm remaining the testing lead um a
lot got misconstrued cuz I said I was
not going to be 100% the time at FEMA
because my current position also works
on ending HIV substance use so I'm still
going to maintain the testing lead but I
am also integrating back into some of my
other office functions thank you for for
clarifying that
um honourable Hanh when is the last time
you spoke to the president about the
pandemics respond and the response it's
been some time since I spoke about the
pandemic response I did have a
conversation in the last couple weeks
would you say that it had been more than
a month ago no ma'am okay dr. Fuji
you've been candid in the past about the
shortcomings of the federal government's
response and what more is needed dr.
Feld she is painful as his spring
shutdowns have been if we don't put in
the effort now expand testing prepare
for a second wave develop national
strategies for contact tracing and
vaccinations could we see our progress
reverse and could we be forced to shut
down again if cases again get out of
control in describing what's going on
it's a very complicated situation in a
mixed bag there are certain parts of the
country certain areas city states that
have actually done very well and are
following the guidelines that we put
together the Gateway phase 1 phase 2
phase 3 New York City is one of them
actually Washington DC is another there
are other areas other states are the
cities that have not done so well I have
a considerable concern about those
because I want to make sure that we get
everything under control it is not there
yet I hope as the weeks and months go by
we will be able to do what you're
referring to and mobilize the
identification isolation and contact
tracing in those states the ones that
have recently been in the news Florida
Arizona Texas and those states that are
now having a serious problem
so it really is a mixed bag we have some
doing really well and some really in
trouble right but dr. factor just to
clarify in the areas where it's it may
get out of control we certainly know
there are states that are doing that now
would you say that we might have to go
backwards and some of the progress may
be taken away and we may have to shut
down yeah I wouldn't necessarily say
yeah first of all I agree with what
you're saying I wouldn't necessarily say
an absolute shutdown lockdown but if
someone is going from gateway to phase 1
to phase 2 and they get into trouble and
phase 2 they may need to go back to
phase 1 I don't think they necessarily
need to go back to lockdown thank you
thank you all with that I yield back
thank you now we go to Delaware mr.
Rochester please unmute Thank You mr.
chairman and thank you so much to the
panel we know that under normal
circumstances uninsurance health
insurance the lack of that as well as
the under insurance of individuals is a
big problem for our country but right
now with the current pandemic and the
high unemployment rate it's an absolute
crisis I don't want to turn this into a
debate about the affordable care act or
Medicaid expansion or any other policy
disputes that we may have the fact
remains that millions of people in our
country are either without health
insurance or they can't afford to use it
and they are especially vulnerable right
now there are close to 30 million people
without health insurance in this country
and for those people it will undoubtedly
be harder to receive testing and
treatment and when a vaccine is
developed they will likely struggle to
access that Mexi doctor Falchi as a
matter of public health would you agree
that during a pandemic such as Kovach 19
it is in everyone's interest for people
to be quickly tested treat it and
ultimately vaccinate it I agree and
doctor Falchi if approximately 30
million people in this country can't
easily access treatment and vaccines
because they lack health coverage
doesn't that present a public health
risk I feel as a physician a scientist
and a public health official that
everyone should have access to the kinds
of things that we're talking about
testing as well as accessibility to a
vaccine and healthcare at moroder ah the
administration has suggested that money
from the provider Relief Fund which is
supposed to help struggling providers is
how it will pay for care for the
uninsured when can we expect a
comprehensive plan from this
administration for how it plans to
provide treatment
vaccines to people regardless of
insurance status the vaccine plan I
think is currently underway as you heard
dr. Redfield do that there are I work
very closely with hersa on making sure
that everyone can get free testing that
program is underway and the claims
reimbursement for treatment is is up to
about a hundred and eighty six million
dollars now so I know that's ongoing and
would be glad to have her so or anyone
else answer any specific more questions
that you would have but I do agree with
the premise again that is absolutely
critical not only in a pandemic but
under any other times that people who
need testing get the testing that
they're you get the health care that
they need and most importantly there are
no impediments whatsoever to getting
vaccinated I don't know if anyone on the
panel could answer this question but
were there conversations about expanding
Medicaid or opening up enrollments for
the ACA to actually mitigate the risks
so
say that I am NOT a member of the task
force but I'm at most of the meetings by
as an invited guest for obvious reasons
and I think there were discussions
across the board about all options all
options were looked at and discussed in
order to make it was clear that the
objective needed to be that no one
should be waiting at home in need of
care because of a lack of coverage and I
would say that every option was really
looked at and the leadership at the
administration at the White House
decided on this way to move forward I I
will reserve my comment to just say that
I think those options would have
brainers I championed legislation
included in the heroes Act that would
require its shores to cover Cove 8:19
treatment with no cost sharing and the
heroes Act also included a provision
that would provide coverage of kovat 90
treatment and vaccines Medicaid for
everyone who's uninsured I sincerely
hope our colleagues in the Senate will
take up the heroes act so that we can
make sure that everyone in this country
can access the treatment and vaccines
they need I yield back the balance of my
time
thank you next is mr. Soto of Florida
please unmute thank you a little bit of
a time line on January 3rd through 28th
president Trump received two
intelligence briefings on the corona
virus according to White House officials
from early January well into mid-march
President Trump deliberately misled the
American people into believing the
corona virus was quote well under
control he declared on several occasions
quote it will disappear and as late as
March 12
he stated quote it's going to go away
the very next day and March 13 he
finally declares the national emergency
approximately 50 days passed from the
time President Trump received his first
Corona
intelligence briefings until he finally
declared the national emergency ad in
six weeks we lost in ramping up testing
at the CDC due to contamination and the
results of President Trump's disastrous
response have been deadly the United
States has more kovat 19 deaths and more
cases than any country in the world over
120,000 Americans are dead 2.4 million
Americans contracted the virus and the
economic fallout has left 43 million
Americans out of work
to argue that president Trump's response
has somehow been a success is really
quite astounding it's our job to conduct
oversight and hold the administration
accountable regardless of the American
regardless of your party so moving
forward
dr. Fauci the house has already passed
the heroes Act which includes 75 billion
dollars in additional coronavirus
testing
contact tracing and isolation measures
how important is this funding to our
continued efforts to combat kovat 19 in
the United States thank you for that
question congressman as we have said
throughout this hearing
clearly testing even more widespread
testing on a surveillance basis is
absolutely essential for us to really
get a full understanding of the
penetrance of this particularly among
individuals who are asymptomatic so the
short answer to your question it's very
important thank you and doctor Falchi
how important is this additional funding
to stop recent increases in koban 19
cases as seen in my home state of
florida again in a tune with what I just
mentioned the more that you understand
the dynamics of the infection the more
that you understand the distribution the
more chance you have of better control
for identifying isolating contact
tracing and concentrating the resources
in those areas will you have the most
problem you won't know that unless you
know exactly what the penetrance is in
your community Thank You commissioner
hon there's a shortage of ram desi beer
in Central Florida in and around my
district well the FDA be able to assist
us with this shortage and have we've
seen other shortages of random designee
across the country
sorry congressman really appreciate the
question we are working closely with HHS
as well as the White House corn of iris
task force who are responsible for the
distribution of the REM desi beer we do
know that we have a supply in this
country and I'm very happy to work with
you and with others so we're glad to
have our folks get in touch with yours
to make sure that there's adequately
supply for Central Florida Thank You
commissioner huh dr. Redfield we saw
after the Asian we lost in ramping up
testing and now do you think that the
United States's relationship with the
World Health Organization is important
to the future of combating violence both
in the United States and worldwide
thank you very much congressman we
continue to have an important public
health relationship with the w-h-o we've
had a long history of partnership with
them I'm currently involved in a number
of very important public health efforts
radication of polio responding the Ebola
outbreak in the DRC developing our
influenza surveillance system across the
nations so we continue that a
partnership at the scientific and public
health level
thank you dr. Redfield and so it's going
to be very important not to defund the
World Health Organization Constance
national interest and with that I yield
back
thank you and last but certainly not
least as mr. O'Halloran brings a smile
to everybody's face mr. chairman members
of the panel thank you for being here
today
I'm going to start out with a forest
fire I've been to three of them last
week because my districts has eight
going on right now and when I get to an
incident control meeting the commander
that is control team is there and then
the division managers for that fire are
all there too or on the phone and being
able to address the issues as are all
the community organizations police fire
emergency response groups they're all on
those meetings and there's multiple
meetings during the course of the week
with the citizens of those communities
at risk and now I'm in a process where
I'm trying to figure out how this whole
process working from the standpoint of
we're here now what's happened happened
we can't change that but going forward
how are we going to address that we have
enough of the testing equipment and
nitrating equipment the tracing
equipment in order to address the issues
potentially in October November and into
the one Whitter how or how are we going
to or will we have a command and control
system that doesn't include 50 people
doing whatever they want to do and that
any ability to react to hot spots as
they occur as quickly as they should may
be and are we going to be ready hot
spots
I have Navajo is my district I have a
White Mountain Apache in my district
wait Mountain Apache over 1500 have
gotten the virus that's out of 12,000
people Navajo the whole nation knows
what what happened on Navajo it took us
weeks to get enough help up there to be
able to address that problem and White
Mountain Apache are still calling me all
the time say where is this and where is
that so is it's obvious that we have a
shortage right now how can we be
guaranteed that we're going to have the
necessary equipment and materials to be
able to address it coming up during a
flu season and the pandemic at the same
time
and then transparency and accountability
I don't know how right now you trace a
transparency and accountability in this
system because it's almost impossible
because nobody takes nobody says that
was my fault
so and I think every one of your groups
has done an outstanding job I just can't
find out what you're doing on a regular
basis
I hear stuffing something on the news
but that doesn't mean that I really end
up knowing what it is so I mr. dr.
Balaji could you explain to me where
were you're at now and how are we going
to attack these hotspots and address all
the issues I just talked about by the
fall and will we be prepared and I guess
most of all is the entire process of how
do we educate the public that has
different ideas and concepts right now
to be able to understand the complicated
nature that all of you addressed here
today and the overwhelming need to
cooperate with one another's as America
always has
dr. pouchy you asked a lot there I'll
try to be succeed in my answer so where
we are now as I mentioned a little bit
ago that it really is a mixed bag it's a
big country it's very heterogeneous and
you can't have essentially a
uni-dimensional approach to the
difference between Arizona and the
things you're responsible for and New
York City metropolitan area some areas
have done very well are well controlled
they're going through the guidelines to
open America others that we've discussed
in detail today are doing poorly and
we're very concerned about them so
you're talking about what about as we
get into the fall in the winter the
first thing that we would need to do is
to try as best as possible to get the
complete outbreak under control so that
everything is at such a low level that
when there are cases that come up you
can contain them as opposed to
mitigating we essentially chasing after
a forest fire that you just mentioned
hopefully we'll get that under control
soon the other thing we need
to do is to get the material which we
are doing and Admiral jawar I'm sure
will comment on that because he's done a
phenomenal job of doing that
getting the PPE getting the ventilators
getting the equipment they we need and
have them in store so that if and I hope
it's if and not when but if we ever need
them
we'll have them and not be in the
situation that we were in in February
and March well we have them by October
November I I believe we will I we
certainly will have the testing that we
did not have early on we will have it by
October with regard to the other things
the PPE s and the other perhaps admiral
jawad can help you with that thank you
again and again this is what we spend
all our time working on under the
cooperation with Department of Defense
and steam on HHS we've already talked
about testing and if you want a person
with accountability it's me if we don't
have it you look at me it's my problem
but the whole testing infrastructure is
really working together the laboratory
supplies the laboratory testing the NIH
program the Barda program is all working
in synergy and I'm coordinating all that
to make sure it happens in terms of PPE
we have a long we had a long way to go
because almost nothing was made in the
United States I mean literally almost
nothing was made in the United States
um I mentioned earlier that a good
example would be the n95 masks an
admiral club check tells me as a result
of everything we're gonna have about a
hundred and eighty million per month
made in the United States by the fall
that's ramping up very quickly
so we feel pretty good about that um and
ventilators were just a good success
story I worked a lot on the ventilator
problem early on I'm an intensive care
physician that's probably the only thing
I do best is work with children on
ventilators but we were very concerned
about that and by July we'll have about
50,000 in the stockpile we only had
19,000 to begin with but we'll have
50,000 so we think we know we're going
to be in good shape for that um and I'm
going to use a word of dr. Falchi I'm
cautiously optimistic but I am very
cautious and I don't still don't sleep
well at night because we have a long way
go and I just want to make the point
that everyone is made it's not like this
is all going to happen to us
the American people have a lot to say
about this and we want to emphasize
following the guidelines following the
phases avoiding mass gatherings wearing
these things using hand hygiene we have
a lot to say about where this is going
to go but we all need to continue to
work together and make that happen thank
you thank you let me thank all of you
for bearing with us for six hours I
guess
and a really thorough analysis of what
is going on so I want to emphasize again
we really appreciate your being here and
your thoughtful responses to everything
thank you so much and I'm going to let
you go because I have a long list here
of documents to read for the record so
you don't have to stay for that but
thank you again I want to remind members
that pursuant to committee rules they
have 10 business days to submit
additional questions for the record to
be answered by the witnesses who have
appeared and I ask each witness to
respond promptly to any such questions
that you may receive and we would like
to insert in the record by unanimous
consent the following documents a letter
from the American Society of
microbiology to the committee dated June
23rd 2020 a letter from the Alzheimer's
Association to the committee dated June
23rd 2020 a letter from ask me to the
Chairman dated June 23rd 2020 a letter
from the American Society of Hematology
dated June 23rd 2020 graph from
representative Olson unco at 19 cases in
the Houston area a statement from
representative Burgess dated June 23rd
2020 and a letter from ranking member
Walden on committee rule 9 B 1 dated
June 23rd 2020 and I'll repeat again
that any member that wishes to a submit
a statement for the record is certainly
encouraged to do so and with that at
this time the committee is adjourned
thanks yeah thank you to everyone
[Music]
[Music]